I was at a dinner party when someone has
stunk up the bathroom and my
brother-in-law at the time said can
bathroom odor be trapped we were just
kind of like what can you do about that
and it's like it's like my body became
electric I work with essential oils as a
hobby and I saw oh my god oil floats on
water like I can do that so then I go
back and I start researching and
studying and mixing like I'm literally
mixing in my kitchen every single day
nobody thought it was a good idea at all
but I had to test it so my husband at
the time pooped three times a day
Wester was a godsend I still thank him
today and then when people would come
over to my house you know family and
friends for dinner you know we'd be at
dinner and I'd be like to go to the
bathroom like everybody thought I was
insane but every time it would work just
a little bit better a little bit better
and I kept getting better at the science
of it you know oh it needs to hover on
the water so I'm like this mad scientist
and my husband walks out of the bathroom
one day and he's holding a product it
looks like he saw it goes he goes oh my
god we're gonna be millionaires
you've taken the smell out of chat I ran
in there I smell OH
this time it works thank you so then I
sent it out to a few friends and said
are we crazy or is this amazing it's
like having that secret that's too good
to keep to yourself because I had sworn
after my second bankruptcy to never go
back in business
I made business the bad guy but then you
have that next child you know you have
that alive thing and I'm like okay here
we go
and that's how Boop restarted
[Music]
now I just want to play and create a
product and it doesn't matter you know
Cooper is 12 years old it's been 12
years you know and yeah people are like
oh it's a phenomenon it's amazing it's
like yeah but we grew really slow
methodically stockpiling a bunch of cash
and I own 100% of the company okay now
we have the world talking about coop
what else can we get people to talk
about you know it's like can we talk
about female empowerment can we talk
about what happens in the workplace so
I'm always kind of visioning out where
the brand can go and I have a lot of
people around there like them well is
this what is within the brand so it's
really a balance between what my
internal vision is and also what how
much the company can handle because I've
lost everything before so I don't want
to play it safe I don't want to not have
fun
so that people think we're okay and so I
protect the brand you know I'm the
person that comes and goes let's do this
and then not compromise with our team
and then I love to bring people together
and then it's like and they always are
challenged to do something they never
thought they could do
it doesn't matter whether people believe
in your idea if you have that knowing
within your body you can come up with an
idea like a poop spray it can become
iconic and you can actually change
patterns and you can change yourself in
the process
that's it global food domination
[Music]